damit
liebe freunde ich das euch heute mal
wieder recht herzlich willkommen heißt
einer neuen episode take on tuesday das
letztes mal so gut ankamen und das ob
mir persönlich extrem viel spaß gemacht
habe sind wir heute wieder an einigen
live streams unterwegs und ich hab mal
wieder ein bisschen geld aufgeladen dass
ich den leuten heute spenden kann nimmt
die linke chance warten gut zu sehen wie
scheiße oder was
[Musik]
wir wollen wir wollen im badezimmer
sehen wir wollen wir wollen wir wollen
ein badezimmer sind wieso hat sie ein
schild auf ihrem bauch wo draufsteht
gemüsepfanne mit schnupfen nudel und hug
540 leute gucken ihn mir beim fordert
spielen zu hat dir 2000 euro gespendet
schreibe ich jetzt noch mal ich bin ich
drin video lukas jungs wenn ihr den witz
erzählt unendlich fünf euro irgendeinen
witz erzählte hettich 55 euro wird
direkt was einfallen mein gesicht
nämlich
machen er kriegt sie dafür seine eigenen
kollegen keine pops für seinen witz okay
der wird zwar kaka hat noch eine chance
ist nicht mehr drin natürlich bin ich
noch drin jungs real talk allerletzte
chance ein guter witz und fünf euro
letzte schadens ein guter witz
wir müssen wirklich einen guten schritt
zueinander drop einbilden wird die
spende 15 euro ist man ganz kurz weg für
zwei minuten ich bin vielleicht wieder
da
luca sagt doch ein witz sogar ein gott
eher ein witz okay dann muss das musste
ja machen ja okay da macht das team
nicht wieder so als könnte nämlich hören
wenn ich mit denen reden einfach
er hat über 2,5
doch hat ikea oder ihr einfach jung sehr
egal das geld kriegt ihr der bananensaft
unterstrich tv ja ansagen machen oder
was eine stunde später wenn wir da mit
dem witz sein schreibt das ist luca guck
mal das ist nun wirklich echt wo habe
weiter doch noch fünf millionen follower
jetzt aber herzlich ich habe schon ewig
keine witze mehr erzählt ich habe keine
ahnung mir fällt kein witz ein
[Musik]
der witz ist dass wir kein witz einfällt
wenn jemand auf der straße zu merken
würde mir sagen würde ich in fünf euro
scheine zement wird sich würde irgendwas
erzählen
außer diese brad pitt kacke das war
nicht lustig vielleicht ein helles
mammut helmut hey okay der ist gut er
ist gut doch was assoziieren setzen
komme ich jetzt hier mike kraus ich habe
keine ahnung ob das jetzt wirklich so
sind aber kriegt er jetzt halt was
treibt nicht
wir sind in 519 oka danke kein ding
braucht der wird zwar ziemlich lustig
[Musik]
folgt mir alle habe ich sag mal so wie
die ihren bruder basis beruht das auf
youtube stellen würde
sagen wir gehen jetzt doch zu einer
letzten person die stream du hast du lg
kyu tae kyu jetzt einfach supporten aber
nicht nur das aussprechen dürfen zehn
euro wenn du ein liter wasser ex den
euro in liter was ich kann ich es dann
langsam trinken mag weder wasser noch
ein lidstrich ein gitter im ganzen tag
für sie mag kein wasser und sie mag
einen liter wti überlebst du denn ein
junger mann in flex gemacht wie du
natürlich zehn euro wenn du 100 ml
wasser ex ich bin jetzt wirklich ganz
weit runter gegangen 100 ml sind zwei
stücke hast du zeit hast der zeitung
dann bekomme ich anrufe weil du spende
hier wieder sonst 100 milliliter 100
milliliter wasser hatten klar ist 250 ja
so nett war das glas treten entspricht
was ich hier auf meinen glauben
allerdings habe irgendwie kannst du ganz
normal wasserträger ist es einfach
wasser ja
einfach hängen wirklich die gefahr
[Applaus]
ich könnte wirklich vereinfachen extras
ohne ohne abzusetzen oder was es
bedeuten dass ohne hat sie das gerade
wieder ausgespuckt
mädel das ist wasser auf dem rad
probiert nein
der kreis gar nix von mir wirklich war
okay das war schwach traualtar und jetzt
was passiert jetzt trinken was wirst du
widerlich erhaltene 10 euro vj überlebst
du denn wenn du warst findest ich hasse
was ich habe es möglich gemacht ist wenn
youtube und kannst du bitte wenigstens
mit schönes bild was trinkst du denn
wenn du wasser widerlich findet wenn du
das hoch jetzt auf seinem youtube kanal
und 77 millionen
doch sprudelwasser hat 10 euro kommen
stellt euch vor sie jetzt live und da
kommt eine person an und sagt hey trinkt
einfach ein glas wasser nicht weil hier
so ein liter oder so ein glas du kriegst
10 euro das glas wasser ist gut für
deine gesundheit und zehn euro
ausgeführt ein geldbeutel so und sie
selber was ich werden einfach vom juca
die nötige wasser zu trinken
riecht sie gerade daran das ist wasser
kommen jetzt echsen ohne absetzen
sie spuckt und jetzt klingelt du kriegst
gar nix von mir alles fragt jemand
anderes in europa verbringen kann ja bei
mir hat gerade postbote klingelt ich
würde die kosten an der stelle durch die
heutige episode von tecdoc tuesday jetzt
allerdings auch beenden wenn die lieben
freunde wenn es euch gefallen hat das
gern einen daumen hoch und nvidia und
schreibt mit mal und in die kommentare
ob ihr wasser auch sechs trainer klopp
findet
[Musik]